people try to steal from behind in the  front court on a fast break  you do it in the backcourt on the  inbound or off of a change of  possessions  what were the sidelines what were your  teammates what were your coaches telling  you like I'm sure they didn't approve  I mean it just happened actually when I  was around like seven grades eighth  grade but I got in trouble for it for a  while you know people tell me you would  not make any team doing that my college  post was like if you do that I'm subbing  you out so I'm like and in the NBA coach  you really never said nothing I think he  didn't know I was doing that first I  think he was lost too I think he was  just looking off the board so he  couldn't really say nothing at the time  but when I did do it I was ready the  ball was stolen so he he liked it he  never told me nothing never told nothing  about it I'm trying to figure out and  this is what